[Música]
esse sou eu há dez anos atrás
o professor de química educador
apaixonado pela minha profissão e hoje
dez anos depois o gestor não é e agora
não teve formação do gestor
eu sempre perguntava o que eu estou
fazendo aqui não é o que eu estou
fazendo aqui porque está dando certo
esta foto eu direi eu tirei a depois de
receber um aviso receber um prêmio como
desenvolvedor de talentos na itália
global education está em 65 países
eu lembro no começo a olhar minha
trajetória neto que deu certo
eu lembro a primeiro dos grandes a fio
ou indo para manaus
estava muito nervoso para assumir a
coordenação geral de graduação e à no 9
ano da conexão eu estava muito nervoso e
eu parei na conexão de belo horizonte eu
comprei um livro chamado o executivo nem
ninguém me decote livros o livro não só
de um livro de química e quando olhei
aquele livro me confortou muito fiquei
muito confortável porque me identifiquei
e quem já leu esse livro ele fala sobre
liderança servidora né eu verifiquei eu
sou um líder servidor realmente eu sou
um líder servidor
isso é da minha educação e comecei a
perceber que quanto mais eu servia outra
mas eu sei vi realmente servir e do
aquele aquele aquela situação aquele
projeto
mas os piratas pessoas as pessoas me
seguiam com aquilo que tem que lembrar
que a liderança em influenciar pessoas e
outro perfil meu também é de meter a mão
na massa assim né
um exemplo vai ter uma ação de marketing
num domingo de noite um militar debaixo
do sol
eu ia lá com meu time sabe eu ia lá com
o meu time eu vou com meu time e eu
sempre sou o primeiro a falar
carrega o peso a me apresento faço de
tudo mas também o perfil também educação
né
ou seja eu lidere pelo exemplo e lidera
pelo exemplo nessa influencia as pessoas
pelo exemplo e eu percebi que as pessoas
querem
elas querem ser inspiradas nela precisam
de exemplos a seguir
tá e hoje sei que meu filho rafinha em
dois anos de idade e se queimam o
aprendizado e aprendizado contínuo de
liderança
neco como influenciar meu filho isso é
um exemplo de liderar pelo exemplo nem
imagina chega para rafinha com a barra
de chocolate na boca rafinha no como
chocolate
a gente vê muito isso ele vê gestores
líderes né que eles falam mas eles não
fazem eles falam bastante mas não fazer
né esse isso pra mim hoje é maior
meu maior aprendizado como influenciar
rafinha a fazer a o que é certo
em um vídeo bem bacana na internet em
que ele mostra um ônibus nesta de
crianças e mães na e pais e as crianças
todas com celular na mão e e pio nesse
ônibus de uma criança como o livro e uma
mãe curiosa geografia assim como é que
se conseguiu que ele não visse o celular
e eficaz no livro ea mãe tava com o
livro na mão nem precisou responder né
e isso é realmente um exemplo pra gente
nem se fala pra vocês não só os gestores
né
são líderes lesão que lhe forneciam as
pessoas que eles fazem
tá então isso é muito importante liderar
por exemplo
e tudo isto é tudo isso eu tenho
aprendido pessoal assim o livro nenhum
foi na prática eu via isso né então
muita parte do domingo 19 o sucesso que
eu tive conversando que o tema eu
percebi isso era um líder servidor
liderava por exemplo né e você vê a
história que grande parte dos gestores e
não faz esse papel de liderança e visão
chefes de seção chefes nem mandar e
mostrar o que tem que ser feito né
e eu como grande cinéfilo
eu adoro final sou apaixonada por fim
mas isso muito firme e bem desse
personagem quando comecei a preparar as
primeiras palestras sobre liderança e eu
me identifiquei muito com o fulham obras
não só pela beleza como vocês estão
vendo
né hoje 11 que não conhece esse filme é
do filme coração valente
nesse filme ganhou um óscar em 2009 95
não me engano né e mel gibson como
diretor do filme este filme conta
história nada no século 13
né rebeldes que vocês brigam para sair
da rodada do domingo da inglaterra né
e qual o perfil do imóvel e só quer se o
filme vai lembrar disso aqui e licá que
ele sempre estava na linha de frente da
batalha
sim é certo ele sempre está na linha de
frente da batalha é o primeiro a correr
a batalha né
e você vê o foco dele também a situação
o foco dele era muito grande e inspirava
as pessoas perguntam de guerra dele né
e vamos comparar com o o rei da
inglaterra o rei da inglaterra ele
estava na retaguarda da batalha não
estava os ingleses na morrendo ele na
retaguarda e teve uma cena do filme an a
dessa cena que eu achei interessante que
ele estava ganhando a batalha e faz
assim manda pirá as flechas podem ter as
flechas
ele queria acelerar a vitória e um
solado deverá sim mas não vai matar todo
mundo inclusive nossos soldados ele
escolheu pra ele assim tem problema isso
né então eu vejo muita questão de
autoridade e poder né ser autoritário
hotel autoridade acho que vai de vocês
aqui são gestores até a empresa né
e você sabe disso assim você tem que
decidir se você vai ter influenciado a
vez da liderança através da sua
autoridade ou usar seu poder de chefe
certo
nisso eu sempre faço a mostrar esse
gráfico aqui se fosse algo que eu criei
que diferencia a autoridade e poder né
eu faço analogia com aqueles jogos de
vídeo game street fighter sabe que tem 1
100 diziam em cima né
toda vez que você usava o seu poder
mágico que acontecia consegue ele
baixava né eu baixava e então faça o
download é bem parecida
você orienta ano toda vez que você usa o
seu poder
seu sangue de unida e baixo então você
tem que saber bem quando você vai usar
seu poder de chefia né
e grande parte das vezes o pessoal se
corrói o relacionamento tem muito
cuidado com isso né
se para inspirar as pessoas e para
influenciar as pessoas e as pessoas
seguem por que você é o chefe e por que
você paga o salário dele certo
isso é ruim o sapesp engajamento de
qualquer empresa né
tem uma frase do gmc hummer não foi
muita da morte executiva liderança é a
questão de mais pessoas de verdade
identificam e satisfazendo sua
necessidade de se doar para casa e
alcançou o melhor desse pessoal a gente
fala amor à gestão já chutaram isso é
tão raro quanto a isso não há nas
empresas é falar em amor pessoal eu falo
muito de amor fala um monte de amor
começou com o time
o amor ágape né se preocupar com as
pessoas né passar a empresa e perguntar
o funcionário estava calado com algum
problema significa que está com um
problema em conversar com ele a opção de
ajuda à cidade de alguma coisa né isso
chamo de amor e da henna e hoje como já
estou hoje eu sou gestor de instituição
de ensino com mais cinco mil alunos e
com mais de 300 funcionários
e faça isso com todo mundo não só com
meus alunos mas também com os meus
funcionários é a minha família eu
considero isso chamo de minha família e
eu percebi pessoal e influência como
lida começou a acontecer muito por causa
disso eu via talentos com e sem procurar
talentos pessoas que eu vi que querem né
a gente fala muito de querer hoje hoje a
como rh
a gente é tão difícil contra uma pessoa
que realmente é sabe não vai pelo
salário já foi tanta promoção eu achava
extraordinário quando fazia a próxima
pessoa a pessoa não perguntava o salário
dela mas quaresma novo salário ela
aceitou porque realmente acreditou no
projeto e ela viu que ela podia crescer
aprender
após a gente fica muito feliz com isso
então assim em todas as pessoas que
trabalham sem falar muito em amor
aí eu me colocava como o desafio de se
relacionar com aquela pessoa
se você tem algum entrave com ela vai
atrás dela vêm acontecendo alguma coisa
grande parte das vezes o pessoal é uma
falha de comunicação
é uma combinação errada é um ranking
antigo é um e mail escrito a um desabe
mal escrito né a não existe esse negócio
de mandar mensagem bote zap
quando você vai ver tem uma mensagem a
pagar seja fica doido né o que tem
escrito aquela mensagem o carro apagou
eu não li na verdade né
imagino uma empresa grande com tanta
pressão e de seu chefe manda pra você um
altza pe
e você já viu a mensagem a pagar seja
fica tenso né preocupado foi que houve
né
outro fator também o líder é do líder
líbio mostra que chama de perfil o líder
orgulhosas a eu nunca desisti nem acho
que o filme nunca desistiu
várias inclusive rodar uma história né
mas ele não até o final ele nunca
desistiu e isso inspira muitas pessoas
pessoal nunca desistir do projeto né
nunca desistir das pessoas também em
outra coisa que é muito importante nunca
deixar de sorrir
nunca deixa de sorrir isso é muita
importância chega no trabalho mesmo que
seja estou você não tem um bom dinheiro
às pessoas as pessoas já ficam tensas as
pessoas que você não bateu meta né
empresa com um problema que vai vender
por exemplo está com um problema em um
bom dia eu já vi acontecer inclusive tá
então nunca vocês são gestores são
líderes nunca deixa de sorrir né por
mais que a empresa ou você tem um
problema mas seu time precisa do seu
sorriso
a mãe de prince seu sorriso isso é muito
importante então tudo que mostrei pra
vocês até agora foi tudo o que eu
aprendi na prática
aprendi na prática me preocupando mais
com as pessoas valorizando mais as
pessoas conversando mais com as pessoas
me relacionando mais com as pessoas e
desafiando elas a fazer o mesmo
então as pessoas me perguntam nada
porque está fazendo para a empresa tem
um investimento tão alto no se responder
que é amor mas só muito estranho mas é
verdade mas preocupa-se a amarem mais
dentro da da empresa
a vitória só queria passar para vocês
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]